[Musique]
après justement on voit les bons jours
c'est pas raisonnable maman c'est
maintenant qu'on n'est pas vacciné de
toute façon c'est la pure folie
on a le masque j'ai les additionnant il
avait la mer je me trouve quoi regarder
notre phrase du jour ce n'est pas une
sanction ce n'est pas un chantage elle
est signée olivier ferrand à partir du
15 septembre si vous êtes soignant que
vous n'êtes pas vacciné vous ne pourrez
plus travailler et vous ne serez plus
payer les soignants craignent aussi les
délais pour prendre un rendez vous sur
d'octo liban tente et personnels de
santé sur paris il faut attendre fin
juillet pour une première injection tous
ne s'arrêtera pas du jour au lendemain
on appellera pas un aide soignant lui
disant tu n'es pas vaccinés tu n'y as
pas par contre il y aura évidemment des
rappels à l'ordre
et oui et la ministre du travail l'a
rappelé c'est ce qui est prévu
d'ailleurs dans le droit commun
aujourd'hui
s'agissant de l'hépatite b ou d'autres
maladies à vaccination obligatoire pour
les soignants oui vous ne pouvez plus
travailler au contact des malades du
congé sans solde ou du congé sans solde
pour aller jusqu à arrêter parce que
j'estime que j'ai le droit de choisir si
je veux me faire vacciner ou pas et tout
en question donc je vais devoir faire
pour mon avenir savoir si je vais rester
soignantes ou si je vais arrêter à cause
d'une vaccination et ensuite un
licenciement si vraiment vous ne ferez
pas vexé mais ma conviction en sophie
lapix c'est que les soignons va être
très nombreux sur vacciner et que la
question ne se posera pas je souhaite
ardemment parce que je souhaite que
chacun puisse continuer à exercer sa
vocation savez comment on fait quand on
est stressé
à trois on crie très fort 1 2 3 ah non
non ça c'est claude françois je ne sais
pas encore si je vais devoir sacrifier
meetic j'aime pour ne pas me faire
vacciner
je ne sais pas encore en fait c'est trop
frais et oui c'est possible je pourrais
me reconvertir
sondage peuple référendum
oui au référendum bien aller c'est
difficile celui là on va faire un dogme
il faudra pour accéder à un spectacle un
parc d'attractions un concert ou un
festival avoir été vaccinés ou présenter
un test négatif récents je me suis pas
encore valcea il faut juste le premier
vaccin
les deux pour faire le vaccin sinon
passez donc toi dans tous les cas le
choix je vais faire demain dans les
minutes qui suivent
c'est la ruée sur les sites pour
réserver les rendez-vous de vaccins sur
la plateforme d'octo lead jusqu'à 20000
nouveau rendez vous sont pris toutes les
minutes
un record ça veut dire quand même quoi
que tous les grands principes de on est
contre le vaccin magnin quand ça
commence à te faire chier dans ta vie
quotidienne tu dépêche d'aller au vaccin
coincer le bâton et la carotte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais plus loin de travailler si je
suis pas vacciné donc vivez comment mal
très mal
avec le sentiment de ne plus avoir le
choix ou comme fanny la peur d'être
exclu et avoir le droit de faire quoi
que ce soit d'aller au restaurant faire
ses courses partir en vacances sinon je
leur ai passé du tout et après on l'a
dit on est plusieurs à l'avoir dit
autour de ces tables les non-vaccinés de
confort là il faut leur rendre la vie
impossible
dans une semaine il faut qu'on ait le
pass sanitaire de tout le monde mais
comment je fais pour le vérifier comment
je suis avec mes salariés qui sont pas
vaccinés je suis pas loin de leur
imposer la vaccination comment je fais
mais comment je fais quand tout d'un
coup une famille débarque au cinéma avec
le petit de 12 ans qui est pas vacciner
parce que le petit de 12 ans avec papa
maman la bonne et moi signe le papier
pour qu'ils soient vaccinés
il ya moins d'un mois non comment il
fait et vous restait confiante
jonnier récente révèle que les gens sa
liberté urbi nommément ces genre de truc
je voudrais juste qu'on précise cette
histoire de masques à partir du 21 avril
dans les lieux publics accueille du 21
juillet je sais pas pourquoi je
m'observe à dire 21 avril à partir c'est
une année c'était une méchante d'abord à
partir du 21 juillet on pourra ne pas
porter son masque dans les lieux ouverts
au public
florian philippot et nicolas dupont
aignan s'en donnent à coeur joie aussi
sur les réseaux philippe de villiers
parle d'un régime totalitaire et sur
twitter beaucoup note l'absurdité de
voir les opposants au pass sanitaires
qui appellent au boycott des endroits
auxquels ils ne pourront plus accéder
c'est un peu t'as pas le droit d'y aller
à bon bah si c'est comme ça j'irais pas
ses fils ce qui inquiète c'est un camion
sans tarder et puis bien sûr c'est sur
les arrondis à refaire le dire ouais je
sais pas et s'épanouit cameron appelle
son fils est un peu costaud ouais je
préfère la nuit ce parce qu'il a oublié
l'épouvantail classique voici la version
améliorée repérer dans un champ en
turquie monté sur un vieux ressorts ce
mannequin n'effraie pas que les oiseaux
surtout lorsqu'on ajoute un filtre vidéo
et une musique adéquate
pas comme en chine où depuis cinq ans un
mystérieux oiseaux noirs terrorise les
hommes d'un campus universitaire car oui
l'oiseau ne s'attaque qu'aux hommes
sa technique est imparable lorsqu'on
s'approche trop près de son arbre il
plonge et les persécutent
au point que les étudiants doivent
passer avec un livre sur la tête pour se
protéger
les autorités ont donc décidé bien de
mettre un petit écriteau fait attention
à l'oiseau ne le provoque et pas et mon
voisin d'armoires qui était très moi je
veux dire il était de la contre allée
ça veut dire quoi il était de la contre
allée elle préfère les garçons à vous
vous dites en belgique il est la contre
allée assez rigolo nous on connaît des
crises pondi en france nous y mange à la
cantine on dit parfois c'est à votre
voisin il était d'accord
[Musique]
tant sur le parquet qu'est ce qu'on
vient de voir si vous l'avez fait
je
oui
j'ai suivi ses droits
[Musique]
j'en ai fait des voyages mais c'est la
première fois de ma vie que je rencontre
un âne à cet appareil